oh my god I just under Raonic Leeside
before a video great I feel really sad I
really feel down right now because I did
I I realized last night that I I can't
keep doing the blogs it really really
sucks I really want to burn about to be
something fun and positive and different
for the channel and I think it was the
first week but now it's just gone to a
point where not just me is being
affected by it but like other people
around me brought in Michael who came
out here to help me with the vlogs
because I was already stressed out
before I came here and I think I have a
pretty high tolerance of stress but it
just got worse and I talked about this
in the vlog it just got worse when I
came here it's just been so stressful
I'm doing the show I'm doing the daily
Blanc's doing Revlimid stuff and it's
just it's just been too much and I can
deal with day like it's just another 10
days right but like even with Marcia
it's like forced to do all these things
it just feels forced right and Michael
everyone is just stressed out over the
blogs and I think the fun disappeared
somewhere and it's like if it's forced
and not fun then what's the point of
continuing it really sucks that I'm here
I really wanted Bart about to be
something fun and positive like I said
but I just can't keep going with it
I'm really sorry that it's if you
expected more I'm really sorry I'm in
this situation it really sucks for me
I've always put YouTube first always
even if I'm working on other projects it
doesn't matter the videos cook goes
first
you guys go come first that's my main
thing but I I can't do that while I'm
here cuz I have to do the show and I
have to do all these other things and
keeping the vlogs up it's just
impossible at this point so I'm really
sorry to you guys for not doing that I
feel really disappointed I wish I could
just make my normal videos again I wish
I was home I miss my pugs but I'm here
for another week and I don't I don't
know how I'm gonna keep doing the vlog
so it's just not worth it I said it
before but I never want to force content
you know I really have a lot of fun when
I'm in my own setup doing my own thing
but I realize just like everyone just
feels forced to film these things and
it's just I'm just really sad about it I
hope you understand I wish I wish it
wasn't like that I know it's not even
that big a deal I don't know why I'm so
[ __ ] upset about it it's just we
really worked really hard on this
[ __ ] thing and I think that's what
killed a which is such a shame and I
think that's why I'm so upset I'll be
back in probably a week and a half to my
normal videos I just need to finish what
I'm doing here in LA I need to put
myself first this time
so disappointed
now you know what send this on a
positive note you guys support while
doing the vlogs really carried me
through and it really means a lot I
don't even know why I care so much it's
[ __ ] stupid you guys have been
awesome thank you I'll be back
it's all good don't worry about me
brofist yeah all right here it comes